dû descendre 2047 il peut je ne sais pas
garde
adib alkhalidey vous attendent mais je
m'en reste préféré et vous venez de dire
dans une de vos vidéos qu'il n'y aura
pas de spectacle avant décembre 2047
vous devez trouver le temps long sur un
horaire à six militaires
moi c'est moi c'est comme ça que ça il
faut il faut que le choix sur un strict
sinon ça marche pas l'heure est grave
il est bientôt 17 heures 17 heures
chanteur en pyjama si pas normal
les deux les deux premières semaines de
la pandémie j'avais pas d'horaires
j'avais pas de calais pas d'emploi du
temps j'étais un peu plus à l'est
propice c'était pas c'était pas bon le
premier ministre a dit au monde
rentrez chez vous restez chez vous moi
mon cerveau ya compris mange tous les
biscuits de la planète je vais je fais
et je faisais que le manger toute la
journée en demandant que ce que j'allais
faire
puis l'a finalement avec un emploi du
temps plus structuré le ch capable de
germi nerpa la bonne couleur s'il n'y a
pas de musique à chaque fois c'est la
même chose ok moi j'ai envie d'y goûter
sa maman j'ai envie d'écouter ça c'est
moi le dj les mêmes goûts musicaux c'est
moi qui décide c'est la plus grosse
paire de couilles
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je veux du cac
mais c'est ma voiture gagne pas ta
voiture ce sont des tableaux débuts dans
le milieu de l'humour vous êtes reconnu
comme un bourreau de travail parce que
sa vie de votre part d'origine irakienne
ou de votre mère d'origine marocaine
je vais donner je vais donner 100% du
crédit à ma mère parce que parce que ma
mère c'est le genre de femme qui ces
genres de femmes qu'on voit dans les
films là c'est le genre de femme qui
avait annoncé une mère monoparentale que
du plus loin que je me souvienne elle a
toujours eu deux ou trois jobs en même
temps c'était dans ma dernière calcul ya
du monde qui parce que que je niaise
mais moi c'est pas c'est pas une blague
c'est que je ma mère elle avait elle
avait une job dans le fond dans une
boutique la semaine avant des vêtements
souvent en soirée à faisait du ménage et
le week end elle avait un kiosque au
marché aux puces
langelier qui est en dessous du walmart
et puis moi mes soeurs à tous les
week-ends on allait avec ma mère au
marché aux puces pire on vendait des
robes avec moi ça me fait rire
parce que j'avais jamais repasser d'un
point de vue adulte il m'arrive mais
c'est drôle de mais je n'imagine mois
dix encaissaient de vendée des robes qui
je t'ai pas si pire que ça
tiens on va passer dans les enceintes
minutes et qui sait vous avez dit que
votre coté travaillant vient de la mer
de votre côté comique à ce qu'il vient
du par en fait moi je dirais mon côté
prise de risque
j'ai mon côté prise de risque qui
viennent mon père du petit monticule est
tellement mon père c'est un gars qui a
fui la guerre qu'elle fait la dictature
de saddam hussein de manière clandestine
après après que sa vie était mise en
fait bill s'est fait menacer de mort des
faits que et il a fui son pays natal il
ya plus jamais il n'y a plus jamais vu
personne de sa famille jusqu'à sa mort
tout récemment au québec c'est il ya
émigré il ya vécu au maroc qui a émigré
du maroc ensuite au canada avec nous il
y avait 75 dollars dans ses poches
c'est quand tu quand tu penses à ces
choses dont tu réalises qui il devait y
avoir quelque chose à l'intérieur de
deux tomes loges de la lignée des
qualités je suis le premier de mon arbre
généalogique avoir des crottes de chien
autour de la route
vous me semblez être un gode famille
parce que dans votre cercle rapproché
dans votre carrière vous travaillez avec
votre soeur et dans vos gars que vous
parlez aussi de votre conjointe la
famille pour vous surtout ouais mais
parce qu'en fait ma conjointe c'est ma
meilleure amie c'est ce qui m'a pas
retenu puis figé pas des directeurs
photo pour faire mais j'ai besoin d'être
puis honnêtement depuis là j'ai tourné
la troisième captive hier ça me prend 20
heures à monter c'est vraiment long mais
mais le tournage en tant que tel se
passe bien parce que ma conjointe me
rejoint est avec moi à me donne des jo
cas quand je commence à être un peu
perdue puis celle qu'elle fût seraient
ceux sur rec fait que ces schémas
directeurs photo à moi
[Musique]
à vos deux films mon ami ou à l'ide dans
votre court-métrage va jouer dehors je
sens que vous aimer profondément l'être
humain avec toutes ses qualités et tous
ses défauts je me trompe
j'ai un parcours de vie un jour je
raconterai toute ma vie aux gens mais
pour leif pas je garde garde des
réserves mais j'ai un parcours de vie
qui m'a fait voir le meilleur et le pire
chez les gens et j'en suis à un point
dans ma vie en ce moment où j'ai
l'impression que la meilleure posture à
avoir puisque c'est moi je n'invente pas
seuls 6 des gens ont eu cette posture la
face à moi dans ma vie puis ça m'a
éduqué
c'est de chercher à voir le meilleur
chez les gens on aurait pu faire un 20
minutes avec adib alkhalidey merci
beaucoup merci à vous j'ai vraiment
passé un bon moment merci